pour la convivialité pour reconnaître
les filles parce que quand on fait du
vélo toute seule on se croise mais on ne
se connaît
pas ce qu'il a de bien c'est que il y a
plusieurs disciplines justement la
natation le vélo la course à
pied
pouvoir partager et puis peut-être
progresser puisque c'est ce qu'on
recherche tout c'est
progresser mais aussi d'apprendre des
bases donc de préparation physique
générale nous sommes pour la deè année
donc au centre Jacques Tessier nous
avons mis en place des stages pour un
regroupement féminin au niveau de de
tous les athlètes triathlètes de lîle le
le triathlon a quand même deux sports
portés et qui sont bénéfique pour le
corps et entre autres pour éviter les
blessures donc on commence par des des
sports portés natation et vélo et on
finit par le plus dur en fait la course
à pied les féminines n'ont pas le
l'esprit compétition et nous souhaitons
àce qu'elle participe un petit peu à des
à des petites à des petits
triathlons
les actions sont en fait pour essayer de
de remotiver un petit peu n nos
femmes au sport de de mieux se connaître
d'abord mieux se connaître par eux-même
par par rapport au sport est-ce que je
peux m'améliorer est-ce que je peux
reconnaître aussi mes mes compagnes que
je croise sur le vélo mais où je dis à
peine bonjour
euh au niveau des filles triathlon euh B
depuis 2 ans on se rend compte que
maintenant on va vers elle parce qu'on
est content de raconter ce que l'on a
fait les entraînements et est-ce qu'on
peut pas faire un entraînement ensemble
euh voilà le sens qui est un petit peu
le fun qu'ell peuvent retrouver la
demande des féminines du coup de se dire
bah tiens on on propuce quelque chose et
de les amener vers vers une ambiance
conviviale et de pouvoir
aussi se se ressourcer un weekend
ensemble